The Joe Rogan Experience that's one of
the things that they were really worried
about when those murder Hornets showed
up yeah the murder ones yeah yeah that
was a fun time what a great name yeah
it's a great band yeah really good yeah
especially the [__] rocking really
murderers
oh yeah I'd wear a bandana that had
their [__] on it that's how you know
you're into the band yeah when you show
up like Dog the Bounty Hunter right yeah
um I think some of them are invasive but
some but obviously they know what the
[__] they're doing they go in there and
they murder everybody I mean that's the
definition of invasives eating someone's
young after you crush them and eating 30
killing just chopping the heads off 30
000 of an invasive murder Hornets are
officially back in the U.S finally
entered the slaughter phase what is this
the purge oh my God so those are the
ones man
did you know that Hornets pollinate too
uh they have to do something they're all
pollinate I figure they serve some
purpose out there they just don't make
honey I don't think I know my
grandmother
honey all day I want to get some murder
Hornet honey what about that honey they
had money yeah I have some you want some
right now yeah we could do it
[Music]
What's it gonna do to us you're gonna
freak out a little bit
we have those shows this evening
I know the guy who owns the club we're
fine yeah
um where's the murderer honey
mad honey it's up there somewhere
yeah where did you get your hands on
murder honey mad honey it's mad honey
it's from Nepal yeah it's those guys
that I've seen those videos honey yeah
yeah
psychedelics a strong word for what I
experienced what'd you experience I
didn't take much so I just experienced
like a light Euphoria it was kind of
interesting apparently if you go too
much it's really rough I love Euphoria
great show great feeling I haven't
watched it but I do enjoy the feeling
you should watch some Snippets of it
I'll send you some clips isn't it like
lunch kids banging each other yeah but
they're of age legally oh good yeah yeah
it's not it's not just [__] deleted
scenes from Epstein's did is that it let
me see
so do you think we shake it
is
I never [__] with that have you [__]
with that no dude it melts people's
brains the tourists Terence McKenna
swore off of it yeah when he was talking
to a guy in an open-air Market yeah and
the guy thought that they were back at
his house oh [__] in the living room
yeah and he realized somewhere along the
line the conversation the guy didn't
know where he was like right now in the
moment in an open-air Market he thought
that he was in his apartment that sounds
like a fun thing to do here on the
podcast
hey man
you're here let's freak it out you're in
Texas I know they love uh mad honey here
he got uh stopped at the uh
um with TSA just a jar of that [__] no
because they were like making making
sure he wasn't traveling with this stuff
after he did the podcast good do we know
the dosage on this James this is totally
legal by the way good that's what that
was my biggest fear was breaking the law
is mad honey legal just take a little
teaspoon just get in there I will take a
little T you go first okay yeah what are
you scared
yeah
that's more than I took the last time oh
good all right
honey it is honey
yeah it definitely tastes delicious it
tastes like it smells don't take too
much I want you to die thank you just
like really get the spoon wet and then
suck it suck the spoon all right I'm
like the Dalai Lama and then think about
all the diseases you could be getting
from me
I don't fear those I think I've got a
good ecosystem syphilis and all that
stuff no I'm not worried thank you
appreciate it you like it right don't go
in again don't go for a second I'm not
going first [__] do it Sam no Jesus
well all right
let's see is this legal
let's find out it's just honey yeah this
is a gag ladies and gentlemen we're
faking it tastes bizarre it's just honey
[__] now my tongue is on fire we'll
wait until it gets to your brain I can't
wait this will be good
Smoke on the Water over here I'm gonna
go full Credence Clearwater yeah oh man
honey
it tasted uh bizarre the label it's
legal to purchase in the United States
according to this there we go it's legal
fully legal it helps in weight
management by the way
um when that guy came in here and gave
it to me and said that he brought it in
that was a lie he lied he got it from
someone who legally purchased it here in
America and he brought it over time wink
wink yeah that's sure what happened
that's what I'm saying yes yes no way
was this he's a good dude there's no way
he would do that
the rules are there because they're good
the rules are only there always because
they're good